we had a one of our viewers Patrick and
he was wondering we're to self-doubt
come in when it comes to screenwriting
we always hear about the lonely
screenwriters well that's a good thing
about being too that you question each
other and if you are able to sell your
idea your concept to the other guy and
pass his master let's say and I history
of approval it's like one way to know
that there's at least a kernel of idea
that somebody else would like that the
world out there may be interested in if
I'm able to convince David for the first
time maybe I will be able to commit more
other people to to be interested in that
script and vice versa we read each
other's I'm increasingly less lonely you
know when will you work with somebody
and I'm really am I other people that
actually right on the wrong and I'll
because I don't know if I'd be able to
just sit in front of my computer facing
the blank page when I'd rather just be
you know seeing across him and you know
just bouncing ideas off hand how you to
know when you have a good film idea I
mean I'm sure the two of you come up
with ideas all the time you're always
thinking about it but how do you know
that this is something that's actually
workable do you ever know I think that
you know when you started like throwing
stones at it and see if it holds up or
if it breaks down you know I think
that's when you know you know if it's
going to work or not you have to try to
poke holes at it and then see if after
that the DA still holds up I think
that's how you know that can be a movie
because there's a lot of problem solving
that goes into actually writing a movie
I'm time as well just a passage of time
if you after a year you're still in love
with the story it's always a good time
now you come up with ideas that feel
great for a week or two and then week
three week for you start like dragging
your faith isn't
them and then you drop them but if
you've been working on it for a year and
you still feel strongly about it it's
that my other time but instead of
fiction I wouldn't wait for a year
because then somebody are just gonna
just come up with something similar at
some point you know when you're working
in science fiction is very dangerous to
wait because you know that there's some
guy out there somewhere who has some
sort of a similar idea so nothing
happens with all genres I mean yeah the
writer of a night crawler and director
what's his name Dan Gilbert thank you i
was saying in an interview how he was
freaked to death while while writing the
script hoping that there was nobody out
there that would beat him to it you know
to write a movie about la local news and
all that stuff so it happens to
everybody thing do you think ideas are
in the ether yeah I mean I think that
they're everywhere and and sometimes you
write a movie and then do make the
mistake of going online on reading the
message boards and that's where
everybody is like reaping your new one
and they're all like saying yeah these
were stolen from these Japanese manga
from the 80s or this was stolen from
this episode of Tales from the Crypt and
you're like I've never read or seen any
of these things you know and it's just
that a lot of people gravitate towards
similar concepts because there are
universal concepts that are appealing to
writers and anything are appealing to
audiences to
you